probably having our hands to David
macbook hair we've had this rather than
the back reminds for a few months we
thought they might come out with some
sort on a portable laptop and we were
right but we never thought it would be
this cool it's aluminum and it's really
small as you can see it's super thin
which means that it's good for the
environment the screen is backlit it's
beautiful also has bathroom
it goes to 1.6 to 1.8 giga hertz also
the coolest part for me is that
incorporates the iphones features and
you can do multi gestures for example in
this gallery here if you go inside and
assume in and then you can zoom out you
can actually do this in yet it's
software it's just an incredible little
thing that it's not in many other local
it just came out with a new itunes movie
rentals so you can actually download
wirelessly through elemental you can
watch it on here as you can see it's
just the film factors beautiful design
it's perfect
you